Toshijinguji
If I didn't have this kind of body
, I'd been with you ever since
I got the patch
.
I don't really like it. I'm not targeting you, and I'm not even
thinking about selling you as a slave,
so don't worry.
Arnold Bugger, so hurry up Cuteness is the
only identity for me right now
If it's denied, what
's left of me?
[Music] For
some reason I can't get through
my charms Ahhh I'm not feeling that kind of squishy Nakata trying to convince
me But on the contrary, I thought that only hatred would come,
let's do
it  At
times
like this,
I'm the King.
As you can see, Jinguji-san chooses my body, so in
this situation, I'm nothing but attractive.
amaran Jingu-ji It
must be attractive to you
[music]
4 re Large silver back